This bonus episode is the second and a four-part series we're calling the future of. We'll be exploring how changes to the way we live, learn, work, and play, may shape our health and well-being in years to come. Thanks to the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation for supporting this episode, the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation is committed to improving health and health equity in the United States. Learn more about them at rwjf.org. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars.
本期特别节目是我们名为“未来”的四部分系列节目的第二集。我们将探讨生活、学习、工作和娱乐方式的改变，将如何塑造我们未来的健康与福祉。感谢罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会（Robert Wood Johnson Foundation）对本集节目的支持，该基金会致力于改善美国的健康状况和健康公平。欲了解更多信息，请访问 rwjf.org。这里是 99% Invisible，我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。
When the pandemic hit, everything that could possibly be done online made the jump, work, job hunting, school, doctors visits, and the shift was hard for everyone. But many Americans didn't even have the fundamental thing needed to make that change. For online learning to work, students and teachers need a fast and reliable internet connection, but dozens of communities across the state don't have that option. When I was in the internet, I have to drive and sit outside
疫情爆发时，所有能在线完成的事情都转到了线上：工作、求职、上学、看病，这种转变对每个人来说都很艰难。但许多美国人甚至连实现这一转变所需的最基本条件都没有。在线学习要顺利进行，学生和老师需要快速可靠的互联网连接，但全国各地的许多社区根本没有这种选择。当我在互联网上时，我必须开车坐在麦当劳外面
of my McDonald's to be able to do my business. Yeah, I'm actually doing that. Yes, well, students were doing that. People without internet access showed up at emergency rooms during a pandemic for non-emergencies because they just weren't able to do a video appointment. And when the time came, there was no refreshing their browser to find out where to get a vaccine. And the lack of access isn't just in rural areas, as is often assumed. About one in five people in New York City don't have any internet access at all, not even through the data plan on their cell phones. It's two decades into the 21st century, and when it comes to life online, large segments of America are still living in the
才能处理我的事情。是的，我确实在这样做。是的，学生们也在这样做。疫情期间，没有互联网接入的人们因为无法进行视频预约，只能在非紧急情况下前往急诊室。当需要预约疫苗时，他们也无法通过刷新浏览器来查看接种地点。而且，缺乏接入的情况并不像人们通常认为的那样只存在于农村地区。在纽约市，大约五分之一的人根本没有任何互联网接入，甚至连手机流量套餐都没有。21世纪已经过去二十年了，但在在线生活方面，美国的大部分地区仍生活在
1900s. So to find out how we got here and what we can do about it, we're gonna be talking to a reporter and long time Front of the show Katie Thorne who's been looking into this for us. Hey Katie. Hey Roman. So Katie, it's 2022. Why don't we have internet? Well, it's actually because AOL didn't deliver enough of those CD-ROMs back in like 1995. Yeah, I mean, that's definitely an old reference. I feel like you're too young to remember those. Yeah, you know, I have like the faintest memories of like teething on an AOL CD. But we're going to actually answer your question about why there's this lack of access today in 2022. First, we need a quick primer on how the internet actually works. Like, what the internet physically is,
20世纪。为了找出我们是如何走到这一步的，以及我们能做些什么，我们将采访一位记者，也是本节目的老朋友凯蒂·桑顿（Katie Thornton），她一直在为我们调查此事。嘿，凯蒂。嘿，罗曼。那么凯蒂，现在是2022年了。为什么我们还没有互联网？嗯，这其实是因为美国在线（AOL）在1995年左右没有提供足够的CD-ROM光盘。是的，那绝对是一个古老的梗。我觉得你太年轻了，不记得那些了。是的，你知道，我对啃咬AOL光盘还有一点模糊的记忆。但我们今天，也就是2022年，要真正回答你关于为什么缺乏接入的问题。首先，我们需要快速了解一下互联网到底是如何工作的。比如，互联网在物理上是什么，
because it turns out Senator Ted Stevens of Alaska was kind of right. The internet is not something that you just dump something on. It's not a big truck. It's a series of tubes. Just so people understand, like, in a sense, the internet really is tubes. It's these bi-brophic cables that run under streets along train tracks and connect with these very large energy-sucking, enormous server farms. This is Greta Byrim. She's been working on community internet projects for over 10 years.
因为事实证明，阿拉斯加州的参议员泰德·史蒂文斯（Ted Stevens）说得有点道理。互联网不是你可以随便往里面倒东西的地方。它不是一辆大卡车。它是一系列管道。为了让人们理解，从某种意义上说，互联网确实就是管道。它们是铺设在街道下、铁轨旁，并连接着那些巨大的、耗能惊人的服务器农场的光纤电缆。这是格蕾塔·拜瑞姆（Greta Byrim）。她从事社区互联网项目已经超过10年了。
And perhaps fittingly for this story, we spoke over a really crappy internet connection. Your tubes were clogged. Yes, yes, exactly. But I think that this sort of tubing is something that most people at this point do understand on a basic level. Like when you scroll Instagram, you're basically sending
为了配合这个故事，我们是在一个非常糟糕的互联网连接下进行的对话。你的管道堵塞了。是的，是的，完全正确。但我认为这种管道的概念是大多数人目前在基本层面上都能理解的。比如当你刷Instagram时，你基本上是在发送
a request to a distant server farm to find a certain piece of data and to send it back to your device. The only wireless part of that transaction is from your device to the Wi-Fi router. But Greta says it's not the case that there is simply a single unobstructed connection going between a server farm and the modem in your home. Instead, the data actually goes through roughly three different layers of internet tubing, or what are sometimes called tiers.
一个请求到遥远的服务器农场，以找到特定的数据并将其发送回你的设备。在这个过程中，唯一的无线部分是从你的设备到Wi-Fi路由器的连接。但格蕾塔说，服务器农场和你的家庭调制解调器之间并不存在单一的、畅通无阻的连接。相反，数据实际上通过大约三层不同的互联网管道，有时被称为“层”（tiers）。
And tier one is these big backbone lines that span the country or go under oceans. These large companies that you've never heard of. So these are companies like Lumen technologies, GTT, the ZEO group. Greta is correct, I have never heard of these. Right, neither had I, but then there's also Tier 2 or what's called the middle mile, which often own like the cables connecting different cities within large regions. And layer two is sort of like transit, like kind of long stretches of towers. And they also don't sell to like individuals or households.
第一层是横跨全国或穿过海底的大型骨干线路。这些大公司你可能从未听说过。比如Lumen Technologies、GTT、ZEO Group。格蕾塔说得对，我确实从未听说过这些公司。没错，我也没有，但还有第二层，也就是所谓的“中间一英里”（middle mile），它们通常拥有连接大区域内不同城市的电缆。第二层有点像交通枢纽，比如长距离的塔架。它们也不直接向个人或家庭销售服务。
So have I at least heard of these middle mile companies? Well, I don't know, Roman, have you heard of stealth communications or fiber noir or my favorite internet? No, I think, yeah, here to form an ignorant of internet. Well, it's okay that you were snoozing on internet because for our purposes, you don't really need to know the names of these companies. All you need to know is that tier one and tier two connections, they're fast. And that's because tier one and two companies only need to connect a few big facilities. So there's kind of like the interstate highway system or the airport hub and spoke system. There's not too many of them and they only go between a few key spots.
所以我至少听说过这些中间一英里的公司吗？嗯，我不知道，罗曼，你听说过Stealth Communications、Fiber Noir或者My Favorite Internet吗？没有，我想，是的，我对互联网一无所知。好吧，你对互联网不了解也没关系，因为对我们来说，你不需要知道这些公司的名字。你只需要知道，第一层和第二层的连接速度很快。这是因为第一层和第二层公司只需要连接少数几个大型设施。它们就像州际公路系统或机场的枢纽辐射系统。它们的数量不多，而且只连接少数几个关键点。
Yeah, precisely. So it's always been relatively affordable for them to lay down these high-capacity fiber lines. And fiber is like the really good stuff. It's basically bundles of flexible strands of glass, the width of a human hair that can handle really large amounts of data. It's by far the fastest and most reliable type of connection.
是的，正是如此。所以对他们来说，铺设这些高容量的光纤线路一直相对负担得起。光纤是真正的好东西。它基本上是一束束柔韧的玻璃丝，只有人头发那么细，却能处理海量的数据。它是目前为止最快、最可靠的连接类型。
But there's one final leap that the data has to make to get to us, Roman. And there's one final leap that the data has to make to get to us Roman. And that's called tier 3. And tier 3 are your local retail internet providers, your spectrums, and Verizon's and such. Yes, finally, we're getting to names I know. Well, good, because it's actually here at tier 3 that our broadband access problems truly begin. Okay, so why is that? that our broadband access problems truly begin. Okay, so why is that? Well, it's because tier 3 companies like Verizon, they might own and operate their own tier 1 and tier 2 networks
但数据要到达我们这里，还有最后一步，罗曼。那就是所谓的第三层。第三层就是你当地的零售互联网服务提供商，比如Spectrum、Verizon等等。是的，终于说到我熟悉的名字了。好吧，很好，因为实际上正是在第三层，我们的宽带接入问题才真正开始。好吧，那为什么呢？因为像Verizon这样的第三层公司，它们可能拥有并运营自己的第一层和第二层网络，
or purchase access from others, but either way, they're stuck with the task of figuring out what's called the last mile. And the last mile is all the millions of tiny connections that go down various streets and under or over people's driveways, etc, etc. And building the last mile, like building the tier 3 piece, it's very physical, like you're going up on the roofs and you're installing equipment and you're dealing with street furniture
或者从其他公司购买接入服务，但无论哪种方式，它们都必须解决所谓的“最后一英里”问题。最后一英里是指通往各条街道、穿过或越过人们车道等等的数百万个微小连接。而建设最后一英里，就像建设第三层部分一样，是非常物理化的，比如你要爬上屋顶，安装设备，处理街道设施，
and like that part is just incredibly difficult. Not to mention big and up roads and varying wires. Totally, totally. And tier three companies are the ones left to do this for entire cities and sometimes entire regions. So even though the last mile sounds way less sexy and high-tech than country and ocean-spanning fiber-backbones, it's way more expensive. Yeah, you can totally see that. Right. So instead of fiber, most people's internet is traveling that last mile over wires that were first laid for totally different purposes, which is why a telephone company like AT&T might also be your internet provider,
那部分工作简直难得不可思议。更不用说挖掘道路和铺设电线了。完全同意。而第三层公司是唯一负责为整个城市甚至整个地区完成这项工作的人。所以，尽管“最后一英里”听起来比横跨国家和海洋的光纤骨干网要逊色且不够高科技，但它却昂贵得多。是的，完全可以理解。没错。所以，大多数人的互联网并不是通过光纤传输最后一英里的，而是通过最初为完全不同目的铺设的电线，这就是为什么像AT&T这样的电话公司也可能是你的互联网提供商，
because you're using the copper lines originally provided for your telephone connection, or the coaxial lines normally used for cable TV. And internet signals can travel over both copper and coaxial, but they're slower than fiber and less reliable. This is when your internet service provider says, oh, we have fast DSL. That just means we're sending signal over our line and watch out if it rains. Your signal might get really fuzzy. So while something like dial-up might be mostly a thing at the past, the truth is copper phone lines still connect a lot of people to the internet over DSL. And even many people's coaxial cable connections aren't fast enough to meet the federal government's
因为你使用的是最初为电话连接提供的铜线，或者是通常用于有线电视的同轴电缆。互联网信号可以通过铜线和同轴电缆传输，但它们比光纤慢，可靠性也较差。这就是当你的互联网服务提供商说“哦，我们有快速的DSL”时的情况。那只是意味着我们通过线路发送信号，如果下雨要小心。你的信号可能会变得非常模糊。所以，虽然拨号上网可能已经成为过去式，但事实是，许多人仍然通过DSL使用铜质电话线连接互联网。甚至许多人的同轴电缆连接速度也不足以达到联邦政府对宽带的定义。
definition of broadband. And what is that definition? Right now, it's 25 megabits per second, download speed, and three megabits upload. And to be clear, you're saying make-up bits here that's only like one eighth of a megabyte. Right. So the speeds that you mentioned, particularly the three megabit upload speed, that's really slow. Like I have a house full of of kids and between all of us,
那个定义是什么？目前是下载速度25 Mbps，上传速度3 Mbps。需要明确的是，你说的是兆位（megabits），这只有兆字节（megabyte）的八分之一。没错。所以你提到的速度，特别是3 Mbps的上传速度，真的非常慢。比如我家里有一群孩子，我们所有人加起来，
that would not even come close to being acceptable. No, definitely not. And this is why getting fiber into neglected areas is so important. But Greta says who gets fiber is determined by the market, and the market is determined not by who wants fiber, but really just who can afford it. fiber, but really just who can afford it? So if you're really lucky to live in a neighborhood where companies see, oh, there's plenty of people who can afford $80 a month internet, so we'll put a fiber line under the streets. But if you live in a neighborhood where they do their market analysis and it looks like folks can't afford that, you're gonna still be on copper or coax. And so even though there are plenty of homes and businesses with fiber connections,
那根本达不到可接受的标准。不，绝对不行。这就是为什么将光纤引入被忽视的地区如此重要。但格蕾塔说，谁能获得光纤是由市场决定的，而市场决定的不是谁想要光纤，而是谁能负担得起。所以如果你很幸运，住在一个公司认为“哦，这里有很多人能负担得起每月80美元的互联网”的社区，那么他们就会在街道下铺设光纤。但如果你住在一个他们进行市场分析后认为人们负担不起的社区，你仍然只能使用铜线或同轴电缆。因此，尽管有许多家庭和企业拥有光纤连接，
for a lot of the country, that last mile remains a deep, vexing problem. And so I wanted to take a look at two examples of cities that were decidedly not rich cities, where people in the last decade went about pursuing this last mile problem into very different ways. Okay, let's do it, which is the first city.
但对于全国许多地方来说，最后一英里仍然是一个深层且令人头疼的问题。所以我想看看两个城市的例子，它们绝对不是富裕城市，过去十年里，人们以两种截然不同的方式处理这个最后一英里问题。好的，我们开始吧，第一个城市是哪个？
Up first is Detroit, Michigan. The statistics in Detroit at that time were abysmal. That's Monique Tate. She's a digital justice advocate and former auto worker who lives in Detroit. And the statistics she's citing are from 2014. And she says at that time, Detroit was ranked as the country's worst connected city. 60% of people did not have a connection that met the minimum definition of broadband.
首先是密歇根州的底特律。当时底特律的统计数据非常糟糕。那是莫妮克·泰特（Monique Tate）。她是一位数字正义倡导者，也是住在底特律的前汽车工人。她引用的统计数据来自2014年。她说当时底特律被评为全国连接最差的城市。60%的人没有达到宽带最低定义的连接。
60% the number is astounding. That paralleled itself with 40% of the people lacking internet connectivity at all. Wow, so 40% of people with no internet, not even on their phones. Yeah, not even on their phones. And you have to remember, at this time in 2014, everything is moving online. So if you aren't online, you are out of luck. Education, economic development and opportunity, which I'm relating to jobs, you are stricot from that. Because if you go somewhere and say,
60%，这个数字令人震惊。这与40%的人完全没有互联网连接的情况相吻合。哇，所以40%的人根本没有互联网，甚至连手机上都没有。是的，甚至连手机上都没有。而且你必须记住，在2014年这个时候，一切都在向线上转移。所以如果你不在线，你就倒霉了。教育、经济发展和机会，我指的是工作，你都被剥夺了。因为如果你去某个地方说，
I'm interested in a job, can I just fill out a piece of paper? No one has that for you to do anymore. They're going to say, if you can't submit your application, we can't even consider you. So Monique watched as job opportunities dried up for folks who couldn't easily apply online. Or as the people who did have smart phones tried to format resumes on them.
“我对这份工作感兴趣，我能填一张纸质表格吗？”现在已经没有人让你这么做了。他们会说，如果你不能提交申请，我们甚至无法考虑你。所以莫妮克看着那些无法轻松在线申请的人失去了工作机会。或者看着那些有智能手机的人试图在手机上排版简历。
And folks were always trying to find places with decent Wi-Fi, particularly around Detroit's North End neighborhood. In the Greater North End, there is, of course, McDonald's, and you could go someplace like that, but there was no local library in the Greater North End. We were not even able to really look to the public provision of a library system. Now, in some of these cases, people weren't able to get online because there was not an affordable option.
人们总是试图寻找Wi-Fi不错的地方，特别是在底特律的北端社区。在大北端，当然有麦当劳，你可以去那样的地方，但大北端没有当地图书馆。我们甚至无法真正指望公共图书馆系统。在某些情况下，人们无法上网是因为没有负担得起的选择。
And at the time, there was also large sections of Detroit that literally had no internet connection. Wow. Like all the tier three stuff we talked about, the wires, the tunnels, just did not exist in some neighborhoods. So I can see why they may not have fiber as an option for the reasons you laid out earlier, but to have no real internet infrastructure at all, no copper, no coaxial, how does that happen? I mean, that can't be random. No, it's not random. Greta says a number
当时，底特律还有很大一部分地区根本没有互联网连接。哇。就像我们谈到的所有第三层的东西，电线、隧道，在某些社区根本不存在。所以我能理解为什么他们没有光纤作为选择，原因是你之前提到的，但根本没有任何真正的互联网基础设施，没有铜线，没有同轴电缆，这是怎么发生的？我的意思是，这不可能是随机的。不，这不是随机的。格蕾塔说，
of years ago, a researcher named Bill Callahan started looking into these patterns, starting with the city of Cleveland. And he got a hold of AT&T's maps of where they were investing in fiber infrastructure, and he lined it up with the old red lining maps from the 40s and found that it's the same streets that are the dividing lines between where the investment's happening and where it's not. Yeah, I have to say that this does not surprise me at all. Yeah, you know, sadly me neither. This is a practice known as digital redlining. An AT&T has said, no, we don't redline,
几年前，一位名叫比尔·卡拉汉（Bill Callahan）的研究员开始研究这些模式，从克利夫兰市开始。他拿到了AT&T关于他们在哪里投资光纤基础设施的地图，并将其与40年代的旧红线地图（redlining maps）进行了对比，发现这些街道正是投资发生与否的分界线。是的，我不得不说这完全不出我所料。是的，你知道，遗憾的是我也不意外。这是一种被称为“数字红线”（digital redlining）的做法。AT&T曾表示，不，我们没有搞红线歧视，
but people have found evidence of digital redlining in Dallas, Toledo, Dayton, Louisville, Moaqy, and also Detroit. And so what was once explicitly racist policy is now just racist economic policy where companies can say, well, we will not recover the money that we put into these neighborhoods. So this is just an economic decision. Race has nothing to do with it, but the outcome is the same. But also Roman, when Internet companies did offer service, they didn't always make their fastest speeds available to everyone. For example, back in the mid 2010s,
但人们已经在达拉斯、托莱多、代顿、路易斯维尔、摩基和底特律发现了数字红线的证据。所以，曾经明确的种族主义政策现在变成了种族主义经济政策，公司可以说：“好吧，我们无法收回投入到这些社区的资金。”所以这只是一个经济决定。种族与此无关，但结果是一样的。但罗曼，当互联网公司提供服务时，他们并不总是向所有人提供最快的速度。例如，在2010年代中期，
when Monique was working with Detroit residents, one of the city's major carriers, Comcast Exfinity, offered a 9.95 a month deal to some low-income residents. They bragged about the fact that they were providing this program that low income people could obtain. In that program, there was 10 megabits of download speed and one megabit of upload speed. Jesus, that is so slow. Yeah, I mean, it is insultingly slow.
当莫妮克与底特律居民合作时，该市的主要运营商之一Comcast Xfinity向一些低收入居民提供了每月9.95美元的优惠。他们吹嘘自己为低收入人群提供了这个项目。在该项目中，下载速度为10 Mbps，上传速度为1 Mbps。天哪，那太慢了。是的，我的意思是，这慢得令人侮辱。
It's not even close to the minimum requirement to be considered broadband. So you're already saying to this underserved and underrepresented group, we're going to provide a substandard product. So given that this was the state of things in Detroit, in the intervening years, like since 2014, what have people been doing to get more access? Because I can't believe it has stayed exactly like this this whole time. Yeah, so what I'm about to tell you is going to kind of sound like kindergarten logic.
这甚至远未达到被视为宽带的最低要求。所以你已经在对这个服务不足和代表性不足的群体说：我们将提供一种不合格的产品。那么，鉴于底特律当时的情况，在随后的几年里，也就是自2014年以来，人们一直在做什么来获得更多接入？因为我无法相信它一直保持这样。是的，所以我接下来要告诉你的听起来有点像幼儿园的逻辑。
OK. But one of the solutions that was hit upon in some of these neighborhoods, and that's still being used in some of them today, started with the idea of sharing. It sounded like a good idea idea and it sounded really simple. It didn't require anything that seemed too illegal. So this is Patrick Crouch. Patrick is an urban farmer who back in 2010 lived in North cork town, which was one of these historically red line neighborhoods in Detroit with digital access issues.
好的。但在其中一些社区中采用的解决方案之一，并且今天仍在其中一些社区中使用，始于“分享”的想法。这听起来是个好主意，而且听起来真的很简单。它不需要任何看起来太非法的东西。这是帕特里克·克劳奇（Patrick Crouch）。帕特里克是一位城市农民，2010年住在北科克敦（North Corktown），这是底特律历史上被划为红线的社区之一，存在数字接入问题。
So, we didn't really have any internet and the house was such that it wasn't wired for telephone and it wasn't wired for cable and I was taking an online class and it was at night, so that was after the libraries had closed, so I was like literally having to ride my bike two and a half miles to a friend who had internet connection that was willing to let me sit and take this class. So Roman, most of Patrick's neighbors also couldn't get good internet either because Comcast didn't service their address or they didn't offer an affordable option. But down the block from Patrick was a software engineer named Ben Choderoff.
所以，我们真的没有任何互联网，房子也没有接电话线和有线电视线，我当时正在上一门在线课程，是在晚上，那时图书馆已经关门了，所以我真的必须骑自行车两英里半去一个有互联网连接的朋友家，他愿意让我坐在那里上这门课。所以罗曼，帕特里克的大多数邻居也无法获得好的互联网，因为Comcast不为他们的地址提供服务，或者他们不提供负担得起的选择。但在帕特里克家那条街上，住着一位名叫本·乔德罗夫（Ben Choderoff）的软件工程师。
You know, he was a computer person. I don't know what he does. He's tried to tell me what he does and I still don't understand it. And you see Ben had this very rare thing in the neighborhood, a cable internet connection. And he was happy to share it with Patrick, but he couldn't just tell him his Wi-Fi password and call it a day. They lived way too far apart for that. So instead, Ben suggested an alternative approach. Um, he started talking about this, this mesh network thing. For me, it was the obvious solution. I mean, it was a super fragile solution, definitely, but it was just like, yeah, we had, we had to solve a problem. This has been, and the mesh network thing he was proposing would go way beyond sharing
你知道，他是个搞电脑的人。我不知道他是做什么的。他试图告诉我他是做什么的，但我还是听不懂。你看，本在社区里拥有这种非常罕见的东西：有线互联网连接。他很乐意与帕特里克分享，但他不能只是告诉他Wi-Fi密码就完事了。他们住得太远了。所以，本建议采取另一种方法。嗯，他开始谈论这个“网状网络”（mesh network）的东西。对我来说，这是显而易见的解决方案。我的意思是，这绝对是一个非常脆弱的解决方案，但就像是，是的，我们必须解决一个问题。这是本，他提议的网状网络将远远超出分享
one lonely Wi-Fi signal with just one other person. Instead it was a way to bring wireless internet to a whole bunch of people all at once. He says he started thinking about it when he was going through some of his old gear. I had a pile of old, little wireless rad radios that were given to somebody who gave them to somebody else who gave them to me. So I ended up with this box of pretty crappy wireless routers. So Ben began handing out some of these free wireless routers to those few neighbors who also had good internet access and then asked if they could share their connections too.
一个孤独的Wi-Fi信号给一个人。相反，它是一种一次性为一大群人带来无线互联网的方法。他说他是在整理旧装备时开始考虑这个问题的。我有一堆旧的、小的无线电台，是别人给某人，某人又给我的。所以我最终得到了一箱相当糟糕的无线路由器。所以本开始把其中一些免费的无线路由器分发给那些也有良好互联网接入的少数邻居，然后问他们是否也可以分享他们的连接。
So he was just like not going to door and hand him some weird old equipment and say, like, please touch us to your modem and give me your password? Yeah, that's pretty much exactly how it happened. Yeah, I mean, like, I already talked to all my neighbors. That made it easier to set up because people already trusted me somewhat. So the way that this whole thing works was that the person with internet access would attach a so-called radio to their normal at-home router. And they'd put that up on their roof or on the side of their house.
所以他就像是挨家挨户分发一些奇怪的旧设备，然后说：“请把这个连到你的调制解调器上，把密码给我？”是的，事情基本上就是这样发生的。是的，我的意思是，我已经和所有的邻居谈过了。这使得设置更容易，因为人们已经对我有一些信任了。所以整个事情的工作方式是，有互联网接入的人会将所谓的“无线电”连接到他们正常的家庭路由器上。他们会把它放在屋顶或房子侧面。
And that radio would basically extend the Wi-Fi signal so folks down the block could pick it up too. And throughout the neighborhood, there were also these little wireless nodes that extended the signals even further. Wow. And then Ben and his neighbors would climb up on the roof of whoever's house they were connecting
那个无线电基本上会扩展Wi-Fi信号，这样街上的人也能接收到。在整个社区中，还有一些小的无线节点，进一步扩展了信号。哇。然后本和他的邻居会爬上他们正在连接的房子的屋顶，
and put up equipment to receive that signal. Then as a final step, they'd connect a wire from that receiver into a home Wi-Fi router and bang. They would be online. So in this kind of giant Wi-Fi router and bang, they would be online. So in this kind of giant, daisy chain of gear, what were the locations in the neighborhood where they installed some of these connections and nodes? Well, so as far as I can tell from talking with Ben, the answer appears to be pretty much anywhere they could.
安装设备来接收该信号。最后一步，他们会把一根电线从接收器连接到家庭Wi-Fi路由器上，砰。他们就上线了。所以在这个巨大的Wi-Fi路由器中，砰，他们就上线了。所以在这个巨大的、雏菊链式的设备中，他们在社区里安装这些连接和节点的位置在哪里？嗯，据我与本交谈所知，答案似乎是他们能安装的任何地方。
So, like, there is this hostile that donated their connection. The other node was in my upstairs neighbor's chicken coop. I think that was it. Did you? Oh, yeah, wait. Yeah, there was another node in an old air stream trailer that was like a food truck. So between these few internet access points
所以，比如，有一家旅舍捐赠了他们的连接。另一个节点在我楼上邻居的鸡舍里。我想就是这样。你确定吗？哦，是的，等等。是的，还有一个节点在一个旧的清风（Airstream）拖车里，那像是一辆餐车。所以在这些少数互联网接入点
and those few nodes, those extenders, they made this web of wireless networks connecting a bunch of neighbors' houses and an apartment building and that hostel. So did the neighborhood need a password or was it just kind of open to anyone? No, you didn't really need a password. Like people who had routers on the network could put a password on their connection if they wanted to, but a lot of people just intentionally left theirs open so that other people could pick it up. Yeah, people would park right next to our house all the time.
和那些少数节点（扩展器）之间，他们编织了一个无线网络，连接了一群邻居的房子、一栋公寓楼和那家旅舍。那么社区需要密码吗，还是对任何人开放？不，你真的不需要密码。比如，网络上的路由器拥有者如果愿意，可以在他们的连接上设置密码，但很多人只是故意让他们的连接保持开放，以便其他人可以使用。是的，人们经常把车停在我们家旁边。
People would just roll up and sit there for an hour or two and do their thing. So it sounds like it worked. Yeah, I mean, according to Patrick, it did. So this is what people that don't know about computers call magic. Yes, I mean, it was essentially magic as far as I could tell. I get that this was definitely better than no internet at all, but was it fast enough to get the job done? Yeah, I was curious about this.
人们会直接开车过来，坐在那里一两个小时，做他们自己的事情。所以听起来它成功了。是的，我的意思是，根据帕特里克的说法，它成功了。所以这就是那些不懂电脑的人所说的“魔法”。是的，我的意思是，据我所知，这本质上就是魔法。我明白这绝对比没有互联网要好，但它足够快来完成工作吗？是的，我也很好奇这一点。
It's true that because it involves sharing a limited number of broadband connections, Patrick said he would save heavy bandwidth things, like downloading music for Saturday mornings. And sometimes that air stream food truck would be out serving food to people. Right. Like doing what it's supposed to do. Like, go feed people instead of being a node
确实，因为它涉及共享有限数量的宽带连接，帕特里克说他会把繁重的带宽任务（比如下载音乐）留到周六早上。有时那辆清风餐车会出去为人们提供食物。没错。就像它应该做的那样。比如，去喂饱人们，而不是成为网状网络上的一个节点。
on a mesh network. Right. Exactly like doing a lunch service. But all in all, Ben's mesh network did the job. Patrick says he'd never even bothered trying to get on Comcast for himself while he was on mesh. I mean, what's interesting about this is that this Mesh network, as an alternate solution to the last mile problem, it is not top down.
没错。就像做午餐服务一样。但总而言之，本的网状网络完成了任务。帕特里克说，当他在使用网状网络时，他甚至懒得去尝试申请Comcast。我的意思是，有趣的是，这个网状网络作为解决最后一英里问题的替代方案，它不是自上而下的。
It's not being solved by Comcast or some other tier three provider. It is really bottom up. The neighborhood is doing it for themselves. Exactly. But I want to be very clear about this. Ben and Patrick definitely weren't the only ones in Detroit using Mesh to fix this last mile problem. It turned out that a lot of folks found themselves converging on this solution, including Monique Tate and Greta Byram. And those are the people of the experts that we talked to earlier.
它不是由Comcast或其他第三层提供商解决的。它真的是自下而上的。社区正在为自己做这件事。完全正确。但我想要非常清楚这一点。本和帕特里克绝对不是底特律唯一使用网状网络来解决这个最后一英里问题的人。事实证明，很多人发现自己都在采用这个解决方案，包括莫妮克·泰特和格蕾塔·拜瑞姆。也就是我们之前谈到的那些专家。
Right. In the early 2010s, Monique and Greta helped form a group promoting internet access and Detroit that would come to be known as the Equitable Internet Initiative. And EII basically approached this idea of a home spun mesh network and really kind of formalized it and scaled it up. They started a process of installing mesh in four different Detroit neighborhoods. And then they trained residents on how to build and fix
没错。在2010年代初，莫妮克和格蕾塔帮助成立了一个促进底特律互联网接入的组织，后来被称为“公平互联网倡议”（Equitable Internet Initiative，简称EII）。EII基本上采用了这种自制网状网络的想法，并真正将其形式化和规模化。他们开始在底特律的四个不同社区安装网状网络。然后他们培训居民如何构建和修复
the networks and paid them for their work. Wow. Wow. Right, but eventually they got so big that they ran into a bit of a problem. As it became more popular, people did start to ask questions because comments were made that I think this might not be legal. Well, I was definitely beginning to wonder if it was legal. Well, technically
这些网络，并为他们的工作支付报酬。哇。哇。没错，但最终他们规模变得太大，以至于遇到了一个小问题。随着它变得越来越受欢迎，人们确实开始问问题，因为有人评论说：“我觉得这可能不合法。”嗯，我确实开始怀疑它是否合法。嗯，从技术上讲，
not not exactly but this sort of realization actually turned out to be a really good thing in the end because it's for them to do something extra cool, which was to just go around Comcast entirely Because in 2018 the equitable internet initiative partnered with a tier two provider. And so that's the kind of company that buys internet access for the up-to-chain, like closer to that big fiber internet backbone. Right, and that tier two provider, called 123Net, now gives the equitable internet initiative multiple free, super-fast, fiber internet
不，不完全是，但这种认识最终实际上变成了一件非常好的事情，因为这让他们做了一些额外酷的事情，那就是完全绕过Comcast。因为在2018年，公平互联网倡议与一家第二层提供商合作。这就是那种为上游购买互联网接入的公司，更接近那个大型光纤互联网骨干网。没错，那家名为123Net的第二层提供商，现在为公平互联网倡议提供了多个免费的、超快的、光纤互联网
access points that EII then distributes wirelessly by mesh. And that means the equitable internet initiative no longer needs to purchase broadband from Comcast or any other Tier 3 provider. Because they are the Tier 3 provider. Precisely, they are Tier 3. And this has increased the connection speeds of their users in some really meaningful ways. For example, their service now includes symmetrical download and upload speeds.
接入点，EII然后通过网状网络以无线方式分发这些接入点。这意味着公平互联网倡议不再需要从Comcast或任何其他第三层提供商那里购买宽带。因为他们自己就是第三层提供商。正是如此，他们就是第三层。这以一些非常有意义的方式提高了用户的连接速度。例如，他们的服务现在包括对称的下载和上传速度。
Because the key is to create not only just consumers, but create producers so that the upload of your content is just as important as the download of someone else's content. So if you decided that you wanted to have a podcast, you could. And the neighborhood network that Monique was the manager of, now delivers free broadband to about 135 households. That's about 500 people. And that's just one of the three neighborhoods
因为关键不仅是创造消费者，还要创造生产者，这样你上传的内容与下载别人的内容同样重要。所以如果你决定想做一个播客，你可以做到。而莫妮克管理的社区网络现在为大约135个家庭提供免费宽带。那是大约500人。而这仅仅是公平互联网倡议拥有运营网状网络的三个社区之一。
where the Equitable Internet Initiative has operational mesh networks. OK, so this brings me to my big question about mesh. These numbers that you're saying, like 125 households in one neighborhood, there's three neighborhoods, that is super admirable. And I'm so amazed and pleased. And it's a real success, but those are small numbers compared to the size of the problem facing the US overall.
好的，所以这引出了我关于网状网络的一个大问题。你说的这些数字，比如一个社区有125个家庭，有三个社区，这非常令人钦佩。我感到非常惊讶和高兴。这是一个真正的成功，但与美国整体面临的问题规模相比，这些数字很小。
So my question, I guess at the end of this is, will this scale? And do we even want an ad hoc mesh network to be something that scales? Is this a work around to a problem that should be solved head on? Yeah, I mean, that is definitely something that I wondered too. Because like you say, it doesn't feel like the solution. Some people are definitely trying to get mesh to scale, but it turns out not everyone who is worked on mesh is convinced that it's a viable way forward, including, and I think this is pretty telling Ben Choderoff, who set up that really early mesh network, background
所以我最后的疑问是，这能规模化吗？我们甚至希望一个临时的网状网络成为可以规模化的东西吗？这是一个应该直接解决的问题的变通方法吗？是的，我的意思是，这绝对是我也想过的问题。因为就像你说的，这感觉不像最终解决方案。有些人确实在尝试让网状网络规模化，但事实证明，并非所有研究过网状网络的人都相信这是一种可行的前进道路，包括——我认为这一点很能说明问题——在2010年左右建立那个非常早期的网状网络的本·乔德罗夫。
2010. I mean, I think I was naively hopeful in the early days, but that full end is definitely waned. The way Ben sees it, the network met an acute need for a while, and he is super proud of what he and his neighbors built together. But he thought of it as more of a conversation starter than anything. I saw that as a political message that could be sent by our mesh networks, like, man, look what we had to do.
我的意思是，我想我在早期是天真地充满希望的，但那种热情绝对减退了。在本看来，网络在一段时间内满足了一个迫切的需求，他为他和邻居们共同建立的东西感到非常自豪。但他认为这更像是一个对话的开端，而不是其他什么。我把这看作是我们的网状网络可以发出的政治信息，就像，“天哪，看看我们不得不做些什么。”
But then it's easy to massage that political message into saying, like, we don't have to change the big systems because we can just build our own. And I think that's a way of ignoring the political organizing that has to happen to actually confront power and change it. I mean, this reminds me of like those like heartwarming go-fundme campaigns for someone to get a kidney transplant. When, you know, like, it's great that people are generous and somebody can get their kidney. But the actual thing that you need is a healthcare system that provides free kidney transplants to everyone. Totally. Like, that would be far more heartwarming. Yeah.
但随后，很容易将这种政治信息转化为：“我们不需要改变大系统，因为我们可以自己建立。”我认为这是一种忽视政治组织的方式，而政治组织必须发生才能真正对抗权力并改变它。我的意思是，这让我想起了那些为某人进行肾移植而发起的感人的GoFundMe活动。虽然，你知道，人们慷慨大方，有人能得到肾脏，这很好。但你真正需要的是一个为每个人提供免费肾移植的医疗保健系统。完全同意。就像，那会更感人。是的。
I mean, I'll confess that I kind of felt the same way, which is actually what brings us to the other city I wanted to talk about. A place where things played out very differently. Because while Detroit was struggling with just getting people online, this other city was busy getting crisscrossed with fiber connections, and they did it by rethinking their entire approach to internet access. We'll find out just what city Katie is talking about right after this. Support for this four-part series exploring the future of health and wellbeing
我的意思是，我承认我也有同样的感觉，这实际上引出了我想谈论的另一个城市。一个事情发展方式截然不同的地方。因为当底特律还在为让人们上网而挣扎时，另一个城市正忙于被光纤连接纵横交错，他们通过重新思考整个互联网接入方法做到了这一点。我们将在之后找出凯蒂所说的城市。支持这个探讨健康和福祉未来的四部分系列节目
comes from the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation, which is committed to improving health and health equity in the United States. Knowing that the healthy, equitable future we all deserve won't simply arrive, RWJF is exploring how new technologies, scientific discoveries, cultural shifts, and unforeseen events like those in today's story may shape our lives in years to come. Through these explorations, they're learning what it will take to build a future Unforeseen events like those in today's story may shape our lives in years to come. Through these explorations, they're learning what it will take to build a future that provides every individual with a fair and just opportunity to thrive, no matter who they are, where they
来自罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会，该基金会致力于改善美国的健康状况和健康公平。深知我们都应得的健康、公平的未来不会自动到来，RWJF正在探索新技术、科学发现、文化转变以及像今天故事中那样不可预见的事件将如何塑造我们未来的生活。通过这些探索，他们正在了解需要什么来建立一个未来，让每个人，无论他们是谁，无论他们住在哪里，
live, or how much money they have. Learn more about their efforts at rwjf.org. If you like thinking about the future of things as we've been doing in this series and you have a hunch about what it will take to build an equitable future, share it. It's shareyourhunch.org. I'm submitting my hunch, so I'm going to shareyourhunch.org and selecting the prompt. I'm noticing that. I'm noticing that more people in their 40s and 50s are having a middle-class crisis in
或者他们有多少钱，都能获得公平公正的繁荣机会。在rwjf.org了解更多关于他们的努力。如果你像我们在本系列节目中所做的那样喜欢思考事物的未来，并且对建立一个公平的未来需要什么有预感，请分享它。它是shareyourhunch.org。我正在提交我的预感，所以我将访问shareyourhunch.org并选择提示。我注意到。我注意到更多40多岁和50多岁的人在职业生涯中面临中年危机，
terms of their careers and thinking earnestly about career changes that do not prioritize income. That's my hunch. Those are from conversations I have with other parents. Check out other hunches and submit your own at sharehunch.org. We're back talking internet access with the reporter Katie Thornton. So Katie, before the break, you were saying that there was another city you wanted to talk about where people had an easier time getting high quality broadband. Yeah, that's right.
并认真思考不以收入为优先的职业转型。这就是我的预感。这些来自我与其他父母的谈话。在sharehunch.org查看其他预感并提交你自己的。我们回来继续与记者凯蒂·桑顿讨论互联网接入。所以凯蒂，在休息之前，你说过你想谈谈另一个城市，那里的人们更容易获得高质量的宽带。是的，没错。
And this is a place that even during the very worst of COVID, more or less managed to avoid all of the connectivity problems we described earlier. In fact, in this one city, pretty much anyone who wanted to get good internet access during the pandemic could get it. And contrary to what you might expect, it's not Westchester County or Gross Point or Newport Beach or any of these Uber wealthy suburbs, it's Chattanooga, Tennessee. Practically overnight, our school shut down. Many of our businesses moved to remote work and being able to go home and immediately access services. Really enabled you to work at home, learn at home with that missing a beat. So who is this? And why does she have so much good news about Tattenuja? So this is Katie Espicef.
这是一个即使在新冠疫情最严重的时候，也或多或少设法避免了我们之前描述的所有连接问题的城市。事实上，在这个城市，疫情期间几乎任何想要获得良好互联网接入的人都能得到它。而且与你可能预期的相反，它不是威彻斯特县、格罗斯波因特、纽波特海滩或任何这些超级富裕的郊区，它是田纳西州的查塔努加（Chattanooga）。几乎在一夜之间，我们的学校关闭了。我们的许多企业转向远程工作，能够回家并立即访问服务，确实使你能够在家工作、在家学习，而不会错过任何节奏。那么这是谁？为什么她对查塔努加有这么多好消息？这是凯蒂·埃斯皮塞夫（Katie Espicef）。
She works at EPB, which is Chattenugas City-Run Electric Power Utility. And the reason she has such good news is because Chattenugas great. But also, because back in the mid-2000s, Chattanooga was kind of like Detroit. Internet access options for most telecom customers were really limited. Chattanooga was in very much an underserved area. While we did have service from two large national incumbents, really there was no competition. And so there was no real driver to provide better services. But I do think we fell into a range of a lot of cities our size and that we were not getting
她在EPB工作，这是查塔努加市运营的电力公用事业公司。她有这么多好消息的原因是因为查塔努加很棒。但也因为在2000年代中期，查塔努加有点像底特律。大多数电信客户的互联网接入选择非常有限。查塔努加是一个非常服务不足的地区。虽然我们确实有两家大型全国性在位者的服务，但实际上没有竞争。因此，没有真正的动力去提供更好的服务。但我确实认为我们陷入了许多我们这个规模城市的范围，即我们没有获得
the best technology. So they were kind of just in this motivational trough where these big providers had no incentive to provide anything beyond the slowest connection. Yeah, but then, and this is the good news part, the city made a really interesting move. They decided that starting in 2008, EPB, that public power utility that Katie works for, should enter the telecom market and become an internet provider. Huh. So EPB would compete with the existing providers to sell internet connections to businesses and households. Yeah, that's exactly right. They already sold electricity to customers, and that's also not free, so why not sell internet access to? And where we landed was using a fiber optic network.
最好的技术。所以他们有点处于这种激励低谷，大提供商没有动力去提供比最慢连接更好的东西。是的，但随后——这是好消息部分——该市采取了一个非常有趣的举措。他们决定从2008年开始，凯蒂工作的那个公共电力公司EPB应该进入电信市场，成为互联网提供商。哈。所以EPB将与现有提供商竞争，向企业和家庭销售互联网连接。是的，完全正确。他们已经向客户销售电力，而且那也不是免费的，所以为什么不也销售互联网接入呢？我们最终决定使用光纤网络。
EPB already had power lines that reached every home and business in town, meaning they could put these super fast internet lines right alongside them. And so, if you be started laying down fiber all over the city. And they could afford to do fiber. Well, actually, yeah, they could provided they got enough customers. Interestingly enough, as we were working through the business plan, we realized we needed about one in every three homes to make this profitable. So did you beat that? We did, we did beat that, no doubt. We secured a greater than a 33 or a 30% take rate
EPB已经拥有覆盖镇上每个家庭和企业的电力线，这意味着他们可以将这些超快的互联网线路直接铺设在它们旁边。所以，EPB开始在全市铺设光纤。他们负担得起铺设光纤吗？嗯，实际上，是的，只要他们能获得足够的客户，他们就能负担得起。有趣的是，当我们制定商业计划时，我们意识到我们需要大约三分之一的家庭才能使其盈利。所以你们达到了吗？我们达到了，我们确实达到了，毫无疑问。我们获得了超过33%或30%的采用率。
from the first month we were in business. So how did those existing ISPs respond to that? Well, it turned into a classic speed war. First, EPB offered a connection that was 30 megabits per second, download speed and upload speed, which was a lot back then. But their competitors weren't going to let that phase them. As you can imagine, they were not ready to give up market share without a fight. So when we launched with the 30-meg product,
从我们开业的第一个月起。那么那些现有的互联网服务提供商（ISP）是如何应对的呢？嗯，这演变成了一场经典的速度战。起初，EPB 提供了一种下载和上传速度均为每秒 30 兆比特的连接，这在当时已经非常快了。但他们的竞争对手并没有因此而退缩。正如你所想象的那样，他们还没准备好不战而降，拱手让出市场份额。所以当我们推出 30 兆产品时，
our competitor came back and they upgraded launched with the 30-meg product, our competitor came back and they upgraded theirs to a 30-meg product. So then EPP upgraded to 50-megs, and when their competitor matched that, they went to 100 and then 300. And in 2010, EPP began offering gigabit services, which was way ahead of the rest of the country at the time. In fact, when we rolled out a gig, we got so many questions over what what what anyone do with the gig. This is just crazy. This is just marketing. But after a while, those gig connections turned out to be really useful for things like streaming high-definition movies or uploading multimedia homework assignments.
我们的竞争对手也回来升级了他们的产品，推出了 30 兆的产品。于是 EPB 将速度升级到 50 兆，当竞争对手跟进后，他们又提升到 100 兆，然后是 300 兆。2010 年，EPB 开始提供千兆服务，这在当时遥遥领先于全国其他地区。事实上，当我们推出千兆服务时，我们收到了很多质疑，问谁会需要千兆网速。这太疯狂了，这只是营销噱头。但过了一段时间，这些千兆连接在流媒体高清电影或上传多媒体家庭作业等方面变得非常有用。
Or it like zooming into every meeting during a pandemic. Right. Exactly. And I think zooming into every meeting during a pandemic. Right, exactly. And I think people have figured out what to do. I don't think there's any argument about what you do with the gig. And so in time, their competitors started offering gig speed services too. And Roman for EPB, this was a goal of theirs all along.
或者像在疫情期间参加每一次视频会议。没错。完全正确。我认为人们已经找到了使用千兆网速的方法。我不认为关于千兆网速有什么用途的争论还存在。随着时间的推移，他们的竞争对手也开始提供千兆速度的服务。对于 EPB 来说，这始终是他们的目标。
The idea was that even if EPB didn't dominate the market, they would foster competition and force the private companies to provide better services. And that's what happened. That is amazing. But also, like, did they ever dominate the market? Did they ever make it to number one? Eventually, yeah, they did. In 2017, we hit a mark of 75,000 customers. 2018, it was 100,000 customers. Today, it's a little over 110,000 customers. And so, do you have a sense of what your market share is right now? We sit at about 68% market share today.
其理念是，即使 EPB 没有垄断市场，他们也能促进竞争，迫使私营公司提供更好的服务。事实也确实如此。这太神奇了。但他们是否曾经垄断过市场？他们是否曾经做到过第一？最终，是的，他们做到了。2017 年，我们的客户数达到了 7.5 万。2018 年，达到了 10 万。今天，客户数略超过 11 万。那么，你了解你们目前的市场份额吗？我们今天的市场份额大约在 68% 左右。
Wow. So those ISPs were right to be afraid. Yeah, they were. And I think that what's amazing about EPPPB is that the other third of people in their footprint who aren't using EPPB, they've already built out the fiber connections in front of those homes and businesses. So all you need to do is sign up, and EPPB will basically wire you up, hand you a modem, and poof, you are online. Which kind of led me to what I thought might be a gotcha question, but it turned out to just be more good news. Did the uptake of the service vary
哇。所以那些 ISP 确实有理由感到害怕。是的，他们确实有。我认为 EPB 最了不起的地方在于，在他们覆盖范围内，那三分之一尚未使用 EPB 服务的用户，其实 EPB 已经在这些家庭和企业门前铺设好了光纤连接。所以你只需要注册，EPB 基本上就会为你接通线路，递给你一个调制解调器，砰的一声，你就上线了。这让我想到一个我以为会是陷阱的问题，但结果却带来了更多好消息。服务的普及率是否会有所不同
depending on household income or depending on the race? You know interestingly enough, no, our take rate is pretty standard across all income. Brackets as well as different geographic areas within our footprint. And part of that is because EPB has long provided an at-cost internet service for low income families. And in the pandemic, they made it free. And all of this has had really real benefits. Economists predicted that citywide fiber
取决于家庭收入或种族吗？你知道，有趣的是，并没有，我们的普及率在所有收入阶层以及我们覆盖范围内的不同地理区域都是相当标准的。部分原因是 EPB 长期以来一直为低收入家庭提供成本价的互联网服务。在疫情期间，他们甚至将其免费提供。所有这些都带来了非常实际的好处。经济学家曾预测，全市范围的光纤
would add 2,000 jobs over 10 years. But according to some studies, it's actually added about 10,000 jobs. And not long into the pandemic, the surrounding county's unemployment rate was 2% lower than the national average. It's really interesting because, here you talk about how EVB rolled out their fiber network and the benefits of it. I almost have to remind myself that you're not talking about electricity. It's really reminiscent of the way New Deal programs, like the Tennessee Valley Authority,
将在 10 年内增加 2000 个就业岗位。但根据一些研究，它实际上增加了大约 10000 个就业岗位。疫情发生后不久，周边县的失业率比全国平均水平低了 2%。这真的很有趣，因为你谈论的是 EVB 如何推广他们的光纤网络及其带来的好处。我几乎不得不提醒自己，你谈论的不是电力。这确实让人想起新政计划，比如田纳西河谷管理局，
transformed electricity from a private commodity into a regulated utility. To the point where it would just seem wrong that someone couldn't afford electricity. And now, EVB is doing the same thing, but for internet access. Yeah, I mean, that's spot on, and that's not just your read of it. In our interview, Katie directly connected EPB's mission here to the TVA, which served Chattanooga. You know, in the 1930s,
将电力从一种私人商品转变为一种受监管的公用事业。以至于如果有人负担不起电费，那似乎是不对的。现在，EVB 正在做同样的事情，但针对的是互联网接入。是的，我的意思是，这非常准确，而且这不仅仅是你个人的解读。在我们的采访中，凯蒂直接将 EPB 在此的使命与服务于查塔努加的 TVA 联系起来。你知道，在 20 世纪 30 年代，
and really throughout the remainder of that century, the way to fulfill that mission was very obvious. It was all about bringing electrification to the valley. It meant jobs, it meant industry, it really meant survival. And actually we think today that high speed internet or access to broadband services does the very same thing. I find this all super inspiring.
在整个世纪的剩余时间里，实现这一使命的方式非常明显。这完全是为了将电气化带到山谷。这意味着就业，意味着工业，它真正意味着生存。事实上，我们今天认为高速互联网或宽带服务的接入也起着同样的作用。我觉得这一切都非常鼓舞人心。
And this seems like the top down solution that really is necessary. You know, like this is all like, we're from the government, we're here to help and they really did help. Yeah, yeah, I feel the same way. So this might be a naive question, but like if it works for Ted Nuka,
这看起来像是真正必要的自上而下的解决方案。你知道，就像那种“我们来自政府，我们来这里提供帮助”，而且他们确实提供了帮助。是的，是的，我有同感。所以这可能是一个天真的问题，但如果它在查塔努加行得通，
why can't work for Detroit? Yeah, or everywhere. Like exactly, I wanted everywhere. I mean, it's definitely not a naive question. I wondered that too. Like, surely, Chad Nuke is proof that all you need to get Americans online is the political will. And this was 10 years ago.
为什么在底特律不行呢？是的，或者到处都行。就像，完全正确，我希望到处都能实现。我的意思是，这绝对不是一个天真的问题。我也想过这个问题。毕竟，查塔努加肯定证明了让美国人上网所需要的只是政治意愿。而这已经是 10 年前的事了。
So why aren't we seeing a ton more of it? So why haven't we? Well, it turns out it's not that easy. There are some things that make Chattanooga a little bit of a unicorn. And one of the big ones is that remember Chattanooga already has its own municipal electric system. Right.
那么为什么我们没有看到更多这样的案例呢？为什么我们还没有看到？嗯，事实证明这并不容易。有些因素使查塔努加成为一个有点独特的“独角兽”。其中一个重要因素是，请记住查塔努加已经拥有自己的市政电力系统。没错。
Right, so that meant that when EPB wanted to run fiber lines, they could just do it. By laying fiber right alongside their existing electric infrastructure that already went into people's homes. And then that electricity actually powers the fiber so they don't need to worry about that part either. Yeah, and most cities just don't have an existing department that's in a position to do that.
没错，这意味着当 EPB 想要铺设光纤线路时，他们可以直接进行。通过将光纤直接铺设在已经进入人们家庭的现有电力基础设施旁边。而且电力实际上为光纤供电，所以他们也不需要担心那部分问题。是的，大多数城市根本没有一个能够做到这一点的现有部门。
And if you're a mayor and you want to set one up, it's going to cost you a ton of money up front. And there's no way you're going to see tangible results before your next election. So it's often a political non-starter. But it just seems like the size and cost of these infrastructure buildouts could be overcome if people really wanted to have a public internet. Like it would be expensive, but it would be possible. Yeah, totally. Like we should make that very clear. Like these things are possible to overcome. But Roman, in many parts of the US, there's one thing that makes it more or less impossible.
如果你是一位市长，想要建立这样一个部门，前期会花费你大量的资金。而且在下次选举之前，你不可能看到任何切实的成果。所以这通常在政治上是行不通的。但这些基础设施建设的规模和成本似乎是可以克服的，如果人们真的想要公共互联网的话。这会很昂贵，但并非不可能。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我们应该把这一点说得很清楚。这些困难是可以克服的。但是罗曼，在美国的许多地方，有一件事让这变得几乎不可能。
There are laws that exist today in the country in specific states that prohibit municipal broadband. Of course there are. Of course they made it illegal. Yeah, I know. I wish that I was more surprised as well. But 18 states effectively have roadblocks that
目前全国某些州存在禁止市政宽带的法律。当然有。当然他们让它变得非法了。是的，我知道。我希望我也能对此感到更惊讶。但 18 个州实际上设置了障碍，
keep cities from offering internet. And in other five states have laws that make it really difficult. And those laws have been pushed by four profit internet companies and they're very powerful lobbying arms for years. And so what are their old sh** arguments against public broadband? Well, I reached out to folks at the two biggest telecom lobbies for this story. They didn't agree to interviews, but traditionally they've said municipal broadband interferes with free markets, that it's not the government's place, et cetera. But Greta says ISPs also argue we've been doing this for decades, so we have the know how.
阻止城市提供互联网服务。另外五个州有使之变得非常困难的法律。这些法律多年来一直受到营利性互联网公司及其强大的游说团体的推动。那么他们反对公共宽带的陈词滥调是什么呢？嗯，我为这个故事联系了两个最大的电信游说团体的人。他们没有同意接受采访，但传统上他们声称市政宽带干扰了自由市场，这不是政府该做的事，等等。但格蕾塔说，ISP 们还辩称我们已经做了几十年了，所以我们有专业知识。
And so, you know, like if you're a local official and you have a big telecom company saying hey we've got that we're gonna take care of it for you. You know that can sound kind of good to a local politician right who's like I don't understand how this stuff works like just fix it for me. And the result is that these lobbies have pretty successfully put the breaks on a lot of municipal broadband. And so in many states and cities and rural areas, private ISPs are the only ones allowed to provide these services. And so, is that true for Detroit? Like does Michigan have these laws that prevent publicly owned ISPs?
所以，你知道，如果你是一位地方官员，有一家大型电信公司说“嘿，我们有这个能力，我们会为你处理好”。你知道，这对地方政客来说听起来可能还不错，他们会想“我不明白这些东西是怎么运作的，只要帮我修好就行了”。结果就是，这些游说团体相当成功地阻碍了许多市政宽带的发展。因此，在许多州、城市和农村地区，私营 ISP 是唯一被允许提供这些服务的机构。那么，底特律也是这样吗？密歇根州是否有这些禁止公有 ISP 的法律？
It does. And although the situation in Detroit has improved somewhat in the last decade, even today, there's still ranked in the bottom 10 for American cities when it comes to internet access. The private ISP model hasn't yielded big changes. All of which has left some people, like Patrick Crouch, feeling almost kind of resigned to their fates. What did you do for internet when you moved? Get conquests, like a normal human being. I mean, are you happy with your service?
确实有。尽管底特律的情况在过去十年中有所改善，但即使在今天，在互联网接入方面，它在全美城市中仍排在倒数 10 位。私营 ISP 模式并没有带来巨大的改变。所有这些让一些人，比如帕特里克·克劳奇，感到几乎认命了。你搬家时是怎么解决上网问题的？找康卡斯特（Comcast），像个正常人一样。我的意思是，你对你的服务满意吗？
No, but it just come to a point where we didn't really have a lot of options. And as I mentioned, Comcast is really the only game in town. Man, so if this is where things are still now, if mesh network won't scale, if municipal owned broadband is logistically and politically hard, where does that leave us? Like, what can be done or is being done from here on out to get everyone good internet that they need? Well, the short answer is no one is totally sure.
不，但已经到了我们没有太多选择的地步。正如我提到的，康卡斯特真的是城里唯一的选择。天哪，如果这就是现状，如果网状网络无法扩展，如果公有宽带在后勤和政治上都很困难，那我们该怎么办？我的意思是，从现在开始，为了让每个人都能获得他们需要的优质互联网，可以做些什么，或者正在做什么？嗯，简短的回答是，没有人完全确定。
The recent infrastructure bill looks like it's going to help with building out fiber in rural areas. And the people distributing a lot of the money to the states are asking explicitly about digital equity in cities. But in those states with bans on municipal broadband, that money is most likely going to keep going to ISPs. And if the past is any indication, those ISPs might just end up using it
最近的基础设施法案看起来将有助于在农村地区建设光纤。而负责向各州分配大量资金的人员正在明确询问城市中的数字公平问题。但在那些禁止市政宽带的州，这些资金很可能将继续流向 ISP。如果过去可以作为参考的话，这些 ISP 可能最终只会用它
to offer further discounts on the same old outdated internet connection rather than building anything new. At least in neighborhoods like Detroit's North End. Which is why, although Greta and Monique both think there's room for collaboration with ISPs, Monique stresses that any solution needs to lie in giving access to those who have long been on the margins of technology. Where do I see things going from here?
来为同样陈旧的互联网连接提供进一步的折扣，而不是建设任何新的东西。至少在像底特律北区这样的社区是这样。这就是为什么，尽管格蕾塔和莫妮克都认为与 ISP 合作有空间，但莫妮克强调，任何解决方案都需要在于为那些长期处于技术边缘的人提供接入。我怎么看未来的发展？
I do look at the provision of Internet as a potential opportunity to execute reparations. Yes, I do. Monique says that whatever happens in the long term, in the immediate future, it's time for big telecom companies to step up. They can't just follow the money and only lay down fiber in the richest neighborhoods anymore. They have to build out. Big Telecom has the largest profit margins in the country.
我确实将互联网的提供视为实现赔偿的一个潜在机会。是的，我确实这么认为。莫妮克说，无论长期发生什么，在短期内，大型电信公司是时候站出来了。他们不能再只盯着钱，只在最富裕的社区铺设光纤了。他们必须进行建设。大型电信公司拥有全国最高的利润率。
So why not give back? CEO say that they are giving to communities in need, will give what we need, give internet, just give us the access, and we'll go from there. So ultimately, it's going to be tricky. The goal of for-profit companies will always be to make money, which is why a lot of people still believe that quality internet access for everyone
所以为什么不回馈社会呢？首席执行官们说他们正在为有需要的社区提供帮助，那就提供我们需要的东西，提供互联网，只要给我们接入权限，我们就会从那里开始。所以归根结底，这会很棘手。营利性公司的目标永远是赚钱，这就是为什么许多人仍然相信，为每个人提供优质的互联网接入
means eventually treating broadband as a right, not just a commodity. And that requires intervention by people who are accountable to votes and not just dollars. But no matter what happens next, if we know one thing, it's that the days of treating broadband as a luxury are over. Well, this is fascinating stuff. Thank you so much, Katie. I appreciate it. Yeah, thank you, Roman. Thanks for having me.
意味着最终将宽带视为一种权利，而不仅仅是一种商品。这需要对选民负责而非仅仅对美元负责的人进行干预。但无论接下来发生什么，如果我们知道一件事，那就是将宽带视为奢侈品的日子已经结束了。好吧，这些内容非常引人入胜。非常感谢你，凯蒂。我很感激。是的，谢谢你，罗曼。谢谢你邀请我。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Katie Thornton, edited by Joe Rosenberg, mixed in tech production by Amita Ganatra, music by a director of sound, Swan Rihau. To Lanye Hall is the executive producer, Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Chris Barube, Christopher Johnson, Lashemadon, Jason Dillion, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Tyler Cooper from the organization Broadband Now
《99% Invisible》本周由凯蒂·桑顿制作，乔·罗森伯格编辑，阿米塔·加纳特拉进行技术制作和混音，音乐由声音总监斯旺·里豪负责。托拉尼·霍尔是执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。团队其他成员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·李、克里斯·巴鲁贝、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉舍马顿、杰森·迪利恩、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马斯。特别感谢来自 Broadband Now 组织的泰勒·库珀
and Finance Professor Bento Lobo at the University of Tennessee, Chad Nuga, who we also spoke to for this episode, but whose voices we didn't get to include. And to Monique Tate and Greta Byram, for the many, many follow-up interviews, they graciously allowed us to conduct. You can find out more about Katie Thornton's writing and audio journalism on our website,
以及田纳西大学查塔努加分校的金融学教授本托·洛博，我们也为这一集采访了他，但我们没能包含他的声音。还要感谢莫妮克·泰特和格蕾塔·拜拉姆，感谢她们慷慨地允许我们进行多次后续采访。你可以在我们的网站上了解更多关于凯蒂·桑顿的写作和音频新闻，
it's Katie Thornton.com, and her Instagram, it's Katie Thornton's writing and audio journalism on her website, it's Katie Thornton.com and her Instagram, it's Katie Thornton, where this week she'll be sharing more about broadband infrastructure, including the story of the Empire City subway. I know it's not a train, but rather a weirdly important tunnel stuffed with wires. We are part of the Stitcher & Series XM Podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California.
网址是 KatieThornton.com，以及她的 Instagram，网址是 KatieThornton，本周她将在那里分享更多关于宽带基础设施的信息，包括帝国城市地铁的故事。我知道那不是火车，而是一条塞满了电线的奇怪而重要的隧道。我们是 Stitcher 和 Series XM 播客家族的一部分。现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Org. We're on Instagram and read it too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Thanks again to the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation for their underwriting support of this special episode. Be sure to check out each episode in this four-part series, The Future of Data Data. And remember, if you have a hunch about what it will take to build an equitable future,
你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我 @RomanMars 和节目 @99PIOrg。我们在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上也有账号。你可以在 99PI.org 找到我喜欢的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及 99PI 的每一集往期节目。再次感谢罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会对这一特别节目的承保支持。请务必查看这个四部分系列《数据的未来》中的每一集。记住，如果你对构建一个公平的未来有什么预感，
share it at shareyourhunch.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 shareyourhunch.org 分享它。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。